[Musique]
de retour sur le plateau des débats des
départementales comme promis on
s'intéresse désormais à la
saône-et-loire et pour débattre des
enjeux de ce scrutin dans ce département
sont avec nous ce soir andré accary
divers 3t président sortant bonsoir
bonsoir également avec nous du parti
socialiste violaine il est bon soir je
reçois également donc dominique l'autre
que nous avons choisi de classer d'y
verser entre vont parler dans quelques
instants bonsoir le divers gauche ivan
maréchal bonsoir soi et du rassemblement
national
aurélien dutremble bonsoir tout d'abord
andré accary je les dis divers droite il
y a 6 ans lorsque vous étiez présenté
vous étiez aux républicains aujourd'hui
vous n'y est plus je suis effectivement
divers droite c'est-à-dire précisé nous
sommes tout simplement j'ai souhaité ne
plus adhérer à un parti politique
proprement dit mais mais être
effectivement du ver droite et divers
centres il ya quelque chose qui vous des
roses s et les républicains pas du tout
mais mais il me semblait que
en plus à la tête d'un département et je
pense qu'il faut être en effet très
ouvert et vous savez on a mené une
politique très pragmatique dans ce
département qui correspondait je pense à
cette sensibilité effectivement vous
êtes élu finalement par tous les
habitants de ce département et je
pensais que en effet le fait de ne plus
être vraiment sous l'emprise ou en tout
cas sous une étiquette toute
particulière eh bien c'était c'était
aussi bien la politique politicienne
pour moi c'est derrière c'est vraiment
une politique pragmatique on va
approfondir d'or dans un app store via
les îles est vous vous êtes toujours
parti socialiste toujours ce département
de la saône-et-loire il ya six ans il
basculait de la gauche vers la droite
aujourd'hui six ans plus tard sur les 29
cantons que compte le département vous
n'êtes présent vous ne portez des
candidats que sur 19 d'entre eux c'est
faible qu'est ce qui s'est passé en six
ans alors je vais nuancer un petit peu
on porte des candidats dans le cadre du
couple gauche 71 sur 22 cantons
exactement c'est à dire 85% du
territoire
alors oui effectivement il ya une
modification et puis vous aura pas
échappé qu'il ya une pandémie entre
temps qui n'a pas favorisé ni des liens
ni le fait de créer une dynamique et
d'aller chercher des candidats sur le
terrain on a privilégié le fait d'avoir
des personnes qui soient vraiment génie
des critiques et à la pause c'est pas la
pandémie non j'ai pas je n'avais pas
terminé
c'est là c'est l'un des obstacles il ya
aussi une partie du département où on
est historiquement faibles on peut l'on
peut le dire et puis il se trouve que
dans la stratégie qu'on pouvait avoir
jusqu'à il ya six mois nous avions une
partie de nos camarades puisque on
s'appelle comme ça quand on est dans un
groupe de gauche en général qui ont
choisi de faire sécession
donc effectivement ça a changé le schéma
sur l'ouest du département
alors cette session justement je me
tourne vers vous dominique lotte vous
étiez au parti socialiste c'est quoi
votre démarche aujourd'hui moi je suis
toujours un homme de gauche je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la situation de notre
pays de notre département de départ dont
un homme de gauche qui a déjà annoncé
qu'ils soutiendraient
tout à fait le président devait venir je
vais venir encore une fois je crois que
la situation d'aujourd'hui avec une
pandémie avec une crise économique une
crise sociale une société qui est
fracturée je crois que il y as besoin
que toutes les bonnes volontés se
retrousse les manches pour apporter les
solutions idoines à nos populations à
nos territoires et c'est ce qui m'amène
effectivement à à me dépasser moi même a
accepté de travailler avec des gens qui
comme moi ont une histoire de gauche
d'autres quittent onu ont une histoire
un plus central voire divers droite et
vous vous dites encore de grosses
aujourd'hui à moi je suis toujours de
gauche et j'en fais la démonstration
tous les jours dans les politiques
publiques que je mène dans ma ville
violaine gillet vous êtes d'accord pour
dire qu'il peut encore se dire de gauche
dominique let mais chacun est libre de
dire ce qu'il veut après on voit les
actes d'accord nous sommes dans les
actes on verra monsieur lot à mais dans
les actes de encore une fois savez il ya
une phrase de jean jaurès que je
reprends bien volontiers ça fait partie
de ma propre histoire
jean jaurès visait le courage c'est de
chercher lalibela la vérité et de la
dire eh bien écoutez je crois que je
suis dans cette ligne de conduite
ils vont aller salle on le voit une
gauche qui affaiblit dans ce département
vous vous présentez donc sous une
alliance qui réunit le parti communiste
la france insoumise et grs
il ya d'autres alliances a dû du même
type ont le voile du du côté de mâcon
avec changer d'ère une également du côté
du du bassin minier
déjà pourquoi c'est vous n'avez pas fait
une alliance que sous une même étiquette
commune entre mâcon chalon le bassin
minier
donc effectivement je représente le
collectif du printemps chalonnais mais
comme vous l'avait bien dit il ya des
dynamiques et des collectifs similaires
sur les différents territoires cédés
dynamique qui démarre de manière locale
donc sur chacun des bassins avec des evs
où l'avait dit aussi d une configuration
un peu un peu différente
l'objectif à terme puisque
le travail que nous menons n'est pas
simplement pour un temps électoral celui
des départementales mais nous avons
vocation à s'inscrire dans la durée et
donc effectivement l'objectif à
belleville une bannière commune la
natalité le plus clair pour les lecteurs
sera est effectivement plus clair mais
après la réalité fait que chaque
dynamique se débloque d'une certaine
manière à un rythme différent mais nous
nous avons vocation à trouver une
bannière commune et avoir un vrai
travail à l'échelle du département
mais c'était bon moment vous pensez avec
une gauche qui a peu aux difficultés
vous avez essayé de les voir un petit
peu gauche 71 pour le m'attendais un peu
effectivement à 7 à cette question le
collectif auquel j'appartiens donc le
printemps chalonnais a effectué mon déjà
d'une part lancé un appel public et à ma
connaissance elle seule qui là qu'il a
fait pour intéresser les citoyens
la preuve je suis sans étiquette et
c'est à cet appel que j'ai que j'ai
répondu il ya eu aussi un certain nombre
de deux réunions de rencontres avec
d'autres collègues et d'autres forces de
gauche qui nous ont fait savoir que soit
la dynamique ne les intéressait pas soit
la dynamique était trop tardive on mais
qui ne s'inscrirait pas dans cette dans
cette démarche donc nous avons poursuivi
notre notre collectif et présenter des
candidats parce que pour la simple et
bonne raison que nous estimons que nous
avons des propositions nouvelles et des
propositions différentes affaires et
qu'il est toujours temps s'est jamais le
bon moment donc il est toujours temps de
les défendre dans un temps lectorale
jeux d'hiver on l'a dit ah vous avez
perdu une partie de vos troupes
certains qui ceux qui se dirigent vers
la présidence actuelle
est-ce que vous avez essayé de tendre la
main ces candidatures là on va
relativiser on parle de deux cantons qui
qui sont partis sur l'ensemble du groupe
la dynamique non l'a créée il ya
maintenant
plus de six mois puisqu'on a travaillé
très longuement avec europe ecologie les
verts avec le parti radical de gauche
on a tenté effectivement d'avoir un
rassemblement encore plus large et on a
travaillé longuement avec le parti
communiste qui effectivement tardivement
a fait le choix de partir sur le
chalonnais avec un appel citoyen on peut
pas travailler pendant six mois et puis
à un mois de l'échéance lancer quelque
chose localement pour un appel plus
ouvert moi je le respecte c'est une
démarche des électeurs feront leur choix
on a préféré le choix de l'unité l'unité
c'est un combat c'est un combat qu'on va
continuer de mener ces des échanges qui
sont très ouverts et qui nous ont permis
aussi d'avoir un programme qui est très
riche
un projet pour la saône-et-loire qu'on a
construit depuis décembre maintenant
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
qui sont autour de nous et pas
contrairement à certains autour de cette
table en un week end le 23 mai je crois
avoir perçu sa sueur sur des comptes
twitter je pense qu'un projet pour pour
un département ça mérite quelques
soirées et quelques mois de travail de
me claude pour la sto convient aussi de
la gauche ont rejoint votre démarche
aujourd'hui nous sommes quatre des
vidéos mais vous pensez qu'à l'avenir ça
pour être pluie je pense que cette
démarche ouvre une logique et une option
que bon nombre de candidates de candidat
et je l'espère de futurs élus es et us
effectivement rejoindre au lendemain du
second tour des élections
départementales
je crois que la fracturation de notre
société encore une fois appel à se
dépasser et que les bonnes volontés dans
un contexte aussi particulier aussi
problématique aussi dramatique
on parle de crise hier social de crise
économique de crise sanitaire
je pense aussi que la crise de
psychologique est encore devant nous or
il est dans dutremble vous au
rassemblement national vous n'avez pas
ce problème vous ne posez pas la
question quoi qu'il arrive vous vous
opposerez à la majorité en place
faufilez la vole bien sûr la première
fois
nous présentons 29 bel ombre sur
l'ensemble du département sur l'ensemble
des cantons
tout simplement ce qui est historique
qui est déjà pour nous finalement un
premier succès avant même l'élection
et puis comme vous le savez on est à
l'heure actuelle on est au sortant
finalement puisque nous n'avons aucun
élu au conseil départemental donc bien
évidemment nous nous positionnons pour
intégrer ce conseil avec notre ligne la
ligne du rassemblement national bien
évidemment nous avons pour ce fait c'est
une première à vous l'avez dit vous êtes
présent dans tous les cantons de ce
département pris avec quand même
quelques fois des candidats qui ne sont
pas forcément résidents du canton
tout à fait tout à fait et nous
l'assumons puisque c'est une élection
départementale la dernière élection
cantonale ou à l'époque il y avait une
réelle importance n'est plus là depuis
2008 l'élection départementale la
première avait eu lieu en 2015 nous
l'assumons clairement et je veux dire il
n'y a aucun problème sur sur ses statuts
ce sont des gens qui connaissent le
département avec des compétences bien
évidemment 80% nos candidats sont
finalement novice en politique c'est
leur première bataille électorale et
donc ce sont des gens qui nous ont
rejoints pas forcément avec l'étiquette
rassemblement national mais en tout cas
il se il s'intègre tout à fait dans
notre ligne puisque c'est pour eux une
façon finalement de s'opposer au pouvoir
actuel vous avez espoir de remporter ne
serait-ce qu'un canton ça va être
difficile alors pour nous le fait si
nous gagnons déjà un canton ça sera un
premier succès bien évidemment mais nous
avons vision sur plusieurs cantons déjà
bien évidemment y aller je reviens vers
vous on le voit en six ans la
la composition politique en tout cas ce
département a un peu bougé quelque part
c'est votre oeuvre après c'est
aujourd'hui les gens les habitants de ce
département les attentes des résultats
plutôt que des cuisines électorales
ils attendent des résultats on a essayé
de remettre les choses en ordre
en arrivant et ensuite on est intervenu
régulièrement sur des thématiques où il
fallait intervenir même si c'était pas
tout à fait la loi même si on est sorti
du cadre de la loi et c'est sans doute
ce qui a entraîné parce que tout
simplement on avait une vision promeut
pragmatique mais céline ces lignes qui
bouge on dit oui au niveau politique est
ce que c'est quelque part aussi parce
qu'ils peuvent
votre oeuvre de votre président je sais
pas si c'est une oeuvre ou quoi que ce
soit ce qui compte c'est s'est entraîné
avec moi et avec mon équipe
le on va dire un mouvement pour régler
les problèmes de ce département
voilà on a un enjeu fort et en plus la
crise sanitaire derrière une crise
sociale une crise économique s'est
ajouté je pense que c'est le moment en
effet d'avoir une démarche on se met
autour de la dame et on sait de trouver
des solutions
alors bien sûr vous avez les axes
classique défini par la loi mais vous
avez des interventions je le dis
pragmatique et c'est là dessus qu'on
entraîne en fait à un mouvement
eh bien on va justement il aura
justement y arriver tout de suite
puisque on va passer aux premiers thèmes
que nous avons retenu pour ce débat nous
avons décidé de nous poser la question
de quel outil pour la saône-et-loire sas
à une population vieillissante et je
vous proposais d' un pour introduire
cette partie de regarder ces chiffres il
concerne la population du département
selon l'insee en 2017 12 5% de la
population avait plus de 75 ans et 19,7
entre 60 et 65 entre 60 et 74 pardon en
bourgogne
seule la nièvre à une part d'anciens
plus importantes et les projections de
l'insee prévoit d'ailleurs que ce
phénomène va encore s'accentuer
andré accary si vous êtes reconduit ce
sera vraiment un des enjeux majeurs du
mandat qui arrive bien sûr mais en fait
c'est le même diagnostic que j'ai pu
faire en 2015 c'est à dire on a en effet
bien sûr c'est la population la plus
importante de la région bourgogne
franche comté la seule loi alors des
choses peuvent bouger ou 6 1
la vue pendant crise sanitaire 2020 2019
c'est le département en tout cas dans le
deuxième département france où on a le
plus de transactions immobilières ça
veut dire une nouvelle population active
arrive ceci dit on a effectivement une
tranche d'âge où en effet il ya il ya un
vrai défi majeur à relever
alors on a commencé à le faire en 2010
est notamment avec l'ouverture de
centres sentiers aujourd'hui c'est 70
médecins général est ce que vous ne
faites pas finalement vous ne traitez
pas à ces questions avec une seule
action
il faut en effet avoir plusieurs
directions et c'est vrai que c'est un
défi important
il ya aussi un autre chiffre inquiétant
notamment lorsqu'on parle du maintien à
domicile
vous avez la tranche d'âge les 50 60 ans
et la moyenne d'âge des intervenants à
domicile
donc c'est un enjeu majeur et c'est un
peu le même on va y venir est juste un
petit peu un petit peu plus tard via les
îles s me tourne vers vous puisque votre
groupe au département a reproché à la
majorité en place de ne pas en faire
assez sur la question de la dépendance
et de ses aides à domicile c'est
effectivement des bouts de verre
prochaine
on a fait des contre-propositions parce
qu'on a des budgets sur lesquels on a
des marges de manoeuvre alors on ne peut
pas juger de tout puisque nous ne sommes
pas invités à la conférence des
financeurs contrairement à d'autres
départements où l'opposition petit être
invités dont l'avion demandé mais ça
n'était pas possible dans ce département
en terme de prise en charge on avait
notamment proposé c'est des propositions
que nous reprenons dans notre dans notre
projet pour la saône et loire c'est
d'avoir le choix
avoir le choix non pas d'être maintenus
à domicile mais de vivre à domicile et
de vivre dignement à domicile et de
faire le choix d'aller soit en ehpad
soit de vivre à domicile de manière
correcte avec une prise en charge qui
soit correcte et avec des temps qu'ils
soient harmonisées aujourd'hui le
travail des aides à domicile pour nous
pas la théorie c'est du concret on les a
invités dans la campagne
d'ailleurs la presse ne s'est pas
intéressée n'a pas voulu venir une
conférence de presse ou des aides à
domicile témoignait de de leurs
conditions de travail
tout simplement c'est donc vous feriez
quoi
si d'améliorer traitement c'est mon cas
d'amélioration augmenter les temps de
prise en charge mettre autour de la
table l'ensemble des parties prenantes
c'est à dire des associations qui
interviennent à domicile pour que un
temps de prise en charge pour un repas
puisse être le même quand on vous donne
une demi heure pour préparer faire à
manger chauffer débarrasser et nourrir
la personne âgée je vois pas comment on
le fait dans la dignité
et ça c'est le rôle du département
d'être un as oublié d'être un animateur
des politiques départementales et un
service public départemental de l'aide à
domicile
c'est possible on en a les moyens et
calculer les tarifs de la dépendance
notamment en ehpad en fonction des
revenus pour baisser le reste à charge
c'est possible aussi on en a les moyens
dans ce département
or il ya du train de propositions dans
ce domaine alors pour nous qui dit une
population vieillissante dans le
département dit santé automatiquement
la première chose à faire pour nous
c'est un moratoire un moratoire sur les
fermetures des l'annonçant fait des
fermetures de lits et également des
suppressions des services de proximité
on a pu prendre des exemples par le
passé un marcinho parle de mon saut etc
et nous devons développer là dessus je
rejoins
le centre départemental de santé qui est
une très bonne chose qui a été faite
avec 70 médecins salariés et pour aller
au delà nous nous souhaitons le
recrutement de médecins finalement
spécialisé puisque ce sont des
professions qui sont un peu éloignés de
la du monde rural et je vois qu autour
du plateau
nous sommes plusieurs à avoir des
problèmes de vue si on parle de tels
mots logis bien évidemment la personne
âgée qui au milieu de la ruralité à des
kilomètres finalement des centres et ben
qui ils ont du mal à se déplacer
ils peuvent pas avoir des rendez vous
dans six mois ou un an bien évidemment
donc ces centres avec le recrutement des
personnes spécialisées ça aiderait déjà
les personnes et nous voulons pour les
personnes qui sont encore plus éloignés
s'ouvrir et discuter sur un bus en fait
un bus
simplement un bus médicalisé pour aller
au plus près de la porte de ces
populations bien évidemment fait acquis
à risque que vous avez à répondre à ces
propositions oui mais en fait on
travaille ces questions puisque quand on
parle de matières domicile il faudra
savoir de quoi on parle
en effet c'est surtout sur un
département aussi vaste où la
problématique de mobilité à toute sa
part et il fallait commencer en effet
déjà elle par l'installation de médecins
généralistes partout dans le cadre en
complément de l'existant et puis ensuite
il faut travailler aussi sur les
équipements télémédecine c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire dans tous les
états y compris dans les centres de
santé
on essaye d'aller au plus proche de la
population et de pour qu'elle puisse en
effet rester à domicile on a multiplié
le notamment le budget concernant les
communes et les particuliers pour
améliorer améliorer l'habitat de façon à
permettre aux personnes justement de
vivre le plus longtemps possible c'est
le souhaite mais ça on n'a pas négliger
non plus
l'investissement dans les établissements
spécialisés les ehpad et notamment la
construction encore dindane ehpad à
virer moi je suis très heureux que la
boj se sentiront s'adresse enfin à cette
question là en sachant qu'ils votent
chaque fois contre le budget qui
concerne les personnes âgées et les
personnes handicapées car on oublie
toujours aussi le travail considérable
qui a été fait et que nous allons
continuer à faire en direction des
personnes handicapées notamment en titre
de prévention viread il était très bonne
et pourquoi voulez voter parce budget
alors moi je veux bien réagir parce
qu'effectivement comme je le disais
précédemment
nous ne votons pas ce budget parce que
nous n'aurions pas affecter les dépenses
de la même façon alors d'un côté on nous
reproche de voter 95% des projets dans
l'assemblée départementale mais oui on
voit de corte budget parce que nous
n'aurions pas affecter l'argent de la
même façon par exemple vous citiez le
parcours des personnes handicapées n'y a
eu aucune création de places dans les
établissements spécialisés pendant
l'ensemble du mandat et je note aussi
que pour ce qui concerne les ehpad si on
enlève irait on a divisé par deux
les dépenses de rénovation dans les
ehpad sur l'ensemble du mandat
donc je crois qu'on a encore quelques
marges de progrès et d'autres
propositions à faire pour affecter
l'argent puisque désormais j'en profite
pour le dire ce département sera une
collectivité qui va gérer des dépenses
et pas des recettes puisqu'il n'y a plus
aucun pouvoir de taux dans ce
département contrairement à ce qui est
affirmé dans beaucoup de tracts de la
majorité sortante en disant que les
impôts ne seront pas augmentés
évidemment ils ne le seront pas puisque
ce n'est plus possible techniquement
vous voyez d un peu de vision très
différente
dominique lotte justement vous vous
tirez une position peu centrale votre
regard sur cette question accompagner le
vieillissement de la population d'un
département comme le nôtre et c'est en
particulier répondre un parcours de vie
nos personnes âgées dans nos territoires
que ce soit des communes plusieurs
bennes ou des communes rurales
elle souhaite une chose en particulier
c'est de rester chez soi le plus
longtemps possible
et après malheureusement arrivent
l'inévitable c'est à dire je suis obligé
d'aller dans un établissement spécialisé
pour répondre à ce parcours de vie il
faut intervenir sur ces deux leviers sur
ses deux pieds donc il faut que le
département soit très volontariste sur
la question de l'adaptation du logement
d'accompagner les professionnels qui
accompagnent ces personnes âgées où ces
personnes handicapées je rejoins ce que
disait andré accary en
professionnalisant en formant en
améliorons en améliorant pardon leurs
conditions de vie de travail de
rémunération
c'est un impératif pour attirer des gens
qui vont à faire carrière dans ce type
de métier il faut véritablement que ce
soit un métier attractif et puis en
ehpad
il va falloir là aussi compléter
l'investissement compter le nombre de
places et puis rendre les conditions de
vie les plus optimale possible parce que
c'est un moment particulier pour la
personne elle-même mais aussi pour les
familles ils vont maréchal quand vous
entendez salle
améliorer les conditions de travail des
personnels des auxiliaires de vie qui
permettent les matches à domicile ça
doit vous séduire
oui effectivement mais je vais revenir
quand même sur ce que disait monsieur
hakkari qui était en permanence à nous
parler de pragmatisme et avec l'idée
qu'il n'y aurait pas de politique de
gauche ou de politique de droite en la
matière et en toute matière de
compétence sociale du département
nous nous pensons qu'il ya effectivement
une différenciation et qui on peut avoir
une vision d'une politique de gauche une
politique de droite sur ces sujets là
effectivement puisque vous vous en ai de
soléa la question des personnels et des
agents qui travaillent auprès de 2 des
personnes âgées
les premiers de corvée qui sont souvent
d'ailleurs des premières de corvée il
faut il faut le noter qu'ils sont aussi
dans des lits des âges qui sont la
plupart du temps assez avancé nous nous
pensons qu'il ya effectivement un
travail à faire sur ce personnel qui est
en souffrance
il est en souffrance et donc les points
les personnes âgées qui sont accompagnés
par ses personnels se retrouve elle-même
en souffrance dont il ya un travail
important à faire sur la revalorisation
du métier de valorisation y compris
salariales sur la formation et également
sur l'adaptation du travail parce que
comme l'a dit monsieur kerry le
département et les vastes et donc on
s'amuse à faire aller les auxiliaires de
vie d'un endroit à un autre avec des
temps de trajet qui sont très difficiles
à assumer qui dans certaines
associations ne sont même pas remboursés
donc on se retrouve avec des gens
complètement exploité
j'ai donc on va travailler quelles
solutions havre est un véritable service
public de d2 aux personnes âgées en en
faisant en sorte que la collectivité
départementale reprenne en main
l'ensemble de ces questions et ne laisse
pas les choses se faire par des gros
groupes puisque actuellement c'est ce
qu'on voit apparaître
on a en permanence des associations qui
sont effectivement à la limite du
déficit et de la de la faillite et qui
sont repris par des gros groupes qui y
voient l'intérêt pour pouvoir le faire
des bénéfices sur sur cette souffrance
souffrance des personnes âgées et
souffrance des personnels qui
travaillent auprès de aurélien dutremble
vous n'êtes pas lésiné lot
je voulais rajouter somme ça me revient
aux travers des propos de mon voisin
à côté de moi cette question de
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
bien sûr ce sont des politiques
départementales
je crois qu'il faut y rajouter un pilier
à notre sécurité sociale
la question de la dépendance n'est
aujourd'hui pas réglé dans notre pays et
que cette question là que ce soit ehpad
où que ce soit accompagnement par des
personnes qui viennent
alors là on réhabilite on est plutôt sur
le débat de la présidentielle où des
légions mais globalement c'est une
question qui intéresse les départements
parce que la question du à cinquième
branche de la dépendance il faudra la
règle et dans notre pays
je me tourne vers vous rien du 37
question des grands groupes vous aussi
vous êtes défavorable
moi je souhaite d'ailleurs revenir par
rapport donc au manque surtout de des
conditions de travail de ses agents
puisque c'est pas les conditions qui
pose problème c'est surtout le nombre
il manque des agents dans les ehpad il
manque beaucoup de monde
et puis nous vous forcément bonnes il
est tombé réussir à les recruter c'est
si facile monsieur hakkari pardon c'est
si facile de pouvoir recruter comme ça
des agents supplémentaires non alors
c'est pas c'est d'abord vous avez les
agents soignants et les agents
d'entretien donc en effet c'est un
contexte particulier mais le recrutement
n'est pas simple en effet sur ces
établissements y compris à domicile
c'est ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure on va manquer de personnes à
domicile si on ne rend pas de
l'attractivité dans ce métier c'est pour
ça que je propose un nouveau gros
chantier qui concernera le même que j'ai
pu mener avec les médecins ça sera
vraiment le défi majeur de ce prochain
mandat se termine excusez moi pas de
souci et est donc pour pour ce
recrutement
je peux comprendre qu'il est difficile
mais nous pouvons
dégager une certaine manne financière
bien évidemment tout simplement en
réorientant du budget il ya 7 millions à
l'heure actuelle 7 millions d'euros qui
sont dépensés par conseil départemental
au près de 390 et ménat qui sont des
mineurs non accompagnés des étrangers
qui sont arrivés en france
clandestinement
bien évidemment ces 7 millions d'euros
ils peuvent aller dans le recrutement
pour dans les ehpad pour les personnels
afin d'améliorer l'accueil et le soin
bien évidemment et nous privilégions
également les mdph à la maison
départementale des personnes à handicap
et également sur un soutien à l' appât
pour justement aller vers le maintien
résidence donc redit risée des crédits
plus tôt oui voilà sur ce domaine là on
va en terminer pour ce premier thème on
va pouvoir aborder un deuxième thème
dans un instant mais juste avant ce sont
les questions flash les questions place
des jours de fête et précise que l'on
vous a donné à l'avant et qui appelle de
votre part une réponse phrase on va
débuter tout de suite avec la première
le candidat doit être le département
doit-il être candidat pour expérimenter
le rsa jeunes ou pas on va commencer par
monsieur acariés faire un tour de table
au delà du rsa jeunes ce qui est
important c'est évidemment que les
jeunes puissent avoir un travail et
c'est ce qu'on a proposé notamment pour
cet été le département
aogo fait long suite à la crise et
accompli lui sur le rsa jeunes oui ou
non le candidat doit-il le département
doit-il être candidat décidément non
mais on favorise l'emploi
monsieur lot moi non plus je ne suis pas
favorable au rsa je ne sais pas ce qu
attendre notre jeunesse
ils attendent une insertion sociale et
professionnelle se détrompent
non car le rsa jeunes
il s'agit finalement un aveu d'échec
d'une politique menée
les jeunes ne souhaitent pas de dz
souhaite une sécurité poignée graves ou
fatales
oui nous sommes favorables au rsa jeunes
puisque c'est une proposition de notre
programme parce que ça permettrait de
résoudre une inégalité de droits sur
cette tranche d'âge et contrairement à
ce qui a été dit sur la table d'à côté
sur l'idée que c'était un assistanat
déguisé nous nous pensons qu'au
contraire ça permet à chaque jeune de
pouvoir construire de manière sereine
son parcours professionnel et son
parcours de vie vivendi l'add on a la
majorité pénale on est responsable
pénalement à 16 en france on peut voter
à 18 ans mais il faut attendre 25 ans
pour qu'on vous tende la main
donc oui si la loi le permet nous
souhaiterions expérimenté en tous les
cas une allocation individuel
d'émancipation pour permettre à ces
jeunes que monsieur accary n'a sans
doute pas vu dans le la commission dead
pendant la crise et qui se retrouvait
sans aucun revenu
c'est donc oui voilà oui deuxième
question le département doit-il financer
ou en tout cas aider à financer des
programmes d'équipement de type de
sécurité de type vidéo surveillance
madame gillet tout d'abord le
département le fais déjà nous l'avons
voté alors il ya quand même des
questions à se poser au préalable de
commandes ont l'accompagnent est-ce qu'à
la communauté éducative notamment est
concerné il est bien évidemment pas
question de filmer à l'intérieur des
collèges des mineurs mais sécuriser les
abords
en prenant en compte les différentes
parties prenantes en les informant et
puis quels moyens humains au bout pour
surveiller oui mais pas n'importe
comment
monsieur l'autre puis monsieur hakkari
oui je suis favorable à je ne retiens
pas le thème de vidéo surveillance mais
le terme de vidéoprotection
c'est complètement différent dans
l'esprit nous avons déjà évidemment
accompagner les communes qui quittent
envie de clignotants casse donc oui ce
dutremble oui pour la vidéo protection
aux abords des collèges et aux abords
des exploitations agricoles pour éviter
les attaques des animaux sont bien
évidemment et des vols monsieur marc et
saad
je vais te celui qui est un peu
différent nous ne sommes pas favorables
à un financement de la vidéosurveillance
pour la simple et bonne raison que déjà
c'est pas à paarl la question des
collèges la compétence première du
département mais que nous préférons nous
outils des compétences sociales prévenir
plutôt que guérir et donc plutôt
investir massivement dans des des
personnels et non des moyens humains
présents sur les territoires et donc par
exemple sur les éducations de les
éducateurs de prévention la sauvegarde
qui sont une politique qui ont été mises
à mal par la plupart des agglomérations
en particulier les agglomérations qui
était gouvernée par lier la question
suivante et de la limitation de
vitesse faut-il rester à 80 ou revenir à
90 km/heure monsieur maréchal puis
dessus à cary nous n'avons pas d'avis
préconscient la matière nous on pense
qu'il soit nécessaire de concerter et
d'évaluer les effets du passage à 80 km
heure pour permettre le retour à 90
km/heure avec des limitations sur les
zones les zones dangereuses mais par
contre marine phrase mais nous accueille
écoute il ya une commission le 12 la
sécurité routière avec le département et
on étudiera notamment les voiries qui
sont dans la continuité des départements
qui ont passé la vitesse à 90 mais on va
le regarder avec beaucoup d'attention
parce que ce qui prime c'est la sécurité
routière donc nous allons le faire mais
d'une manière très posé et avec la vie
dans une fois qu'on aura passé la
sécurité rockeur et bien si sommes en
majorité on demandera la vire tous les
élus du département
séduite rendre oui pour le passage à 90
km/heure comme plus de la moitié des
départements qu'ils ont déjà engagé
samedi là avec un équilibre entre la
sécurité la continuité les parcours
pourquoi pas on peut se poser la
question mais jusqu'à présent sujet n'a
jamais été abordé avec les élus du
conseil départemental avec une carte et
des éléments donc difficile de vous
répondre mais ce lot
oui mais faisons de la dentelle c'est à
dire travaillons la chose sur une carte
comme l'a dit violaine gilet avec
concertation des élus concertation des
associations de sécurité routière de la
dentelle dernière question flassa la
saône et loire est un territoire qui est
vaste et divers si vous deviez réussir
en une phrase a donné une définition de
ce département monsieur dutremble notre
département c'est la beauté de notre
patrimoine avec des territoires
différents tellement que le département
est vaste
je veux dire on peut croire qu'on a
changé de département entre la braise et
gérard et donc oui la beauté ça soit je
ne sais plus qui a dit que la saône et
loire était une petite france c'est
effectivement le cas entre des paysages
une histoire un patrimoine une industrie
une agriculture
madame gillet j'hésite entre las
martinés rabelais mais je retiendrai la
douceur de vivre ces marais salle je
vais pas être original où j'estime que
effectivement c'est un département qui
al'avantage est à taille humaine qui
pèse possédant un réseau d'agglomération
et de villes moyennes qui peut qui lui
permet de s'appuyer sur son histoire à
la fois industriel et agricole etc à une
variété de paysages qui est admiré par
beaucoup j'ai dit plein de fois la saône
et loire c'est la petite france
évidemment on a tout ce que l'on
retrouve à l'échelle de la nation et et
avoir une douceur mais aussi un
potentiel sensationnel merci d'avoir
joué deux heures va passer maintenant
donc au deuxième thème de ce débat
comment dynamiser l'attractivité
touristique de la saône-et-loire et pour
l'introduire je vous propose est bien de
regarder ce chiffre qui va s'afficher
5560 c'est le nombre d'emplois directs
générés par l'activité touristique en
2017 d'après l'insee déjà andré accary
se chiffre à 1560 on l'a trouvée c'est
celui de 2017 c'est plus que ça en tout
cas cette en progression évidemment pour
nous c'est un axe un axe majeur où on a
commencé à développer plusieurs
politiques déjà sur l'opération quand on
est arrivé aux affaires
si vous les 80 % du fonds que c'est
enfin du budget était sur du
fonctionnement aujourd'hui on a inversé
les choses on investit beaucoup sur le
tourisme avec des créations ou de 71
avec avec un réseau d'ambassadeurs avec
des voies vertes avec vraiment une
multiplication est aussi une promotion à
l'extérieur on l'a fait au niveau
national notamment pour aider cette
sortie de
de crise pour inviter les gens à venir
avec un gros budget publicité bien sûr
et je peux vous dire que ça fait combien
des styles dans la ville en fête sur si
on a vraiment démarré l'année dernière
pour sortir la crise de la crise et
donner un vrai coup de main et bien nos
opérateurs sur le territoire je pense
aux restaurateurs à tous ceux qui
avaient le ridou fermé et donc on essaye
vraiment d'être à l'extérieur et donc
conduire vraiment une politique
bon la dernière campagne publicitaire
c'est en effet plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros on est sur un budget de
350 millions 1000 euros sur une campagne
publicitaire mais sûre d'aimer la
promotion est beaucoup plus importante
mais en tout cas c'est vrai que on a
vraiment réorienter on laisse beaucoup
on mise beaucoup justement pour inviter
les gens n'ont que lorsqu'ils passent en
saône-et-loire revenir dans ce
territoire et a profité finalement de ce
terroir de toutes ces spécificités de ce
département
l'économie dans tous les jeux très
importante correspond à peu la parole il
vendrait cet investissement vous le vous
le soutenez vous le comprenez on mistrot
sur le tourisme ou non non je ne suis ne
sais pas si on mr sur le tourisme c'est
un des acteurs est un des secteurs
d'activité qui peut être celui de du
département il doit pas remplacer
il doit pas se substituer à la filière
industrielle et à l'agriculture
après sur ce qui a été fait moi j'ai
tendance à dire que la communication
elle vient comme un dernier étage de la
fusée elle vient pour valoriser une
offre touristique est constitué et donc
ce qui manque sur ce territoire c'est
effectivement plus tout d'avoir un vrai
travail de structuration et des
qualifications de l'offre touristique et
on s'intéressera sans doute après à la
communication
pourquoi parce que déjà c'est plutôt la
région qui est compétente en matière de
tourisme
alors que peut faire de manière
complémentaire le département en étant
plus en proximité c'est justement de
coordonner les acteurs du tourisme sur
les différents territoires on vient de
dire que le territoire était très varié
il faut aller au plus près d'eux est
donc peut-être que monsieur accary
préféré enlever du fonctionnement et
faire de l'investissement avec des
campagnes de pub
nous préférons contraire mettre en place
des personnes qui coordonneront sur
l'ensemble du territoire les l'offre de
l'offre touristique et un gilet je vois
deux visions différentes laquelle je
vais rejoindre mon voisin c'est
effectivement le fonctionnement qui a
été enlevée il faut appeler un chat un
chat ce sont des licenciements à l'
agence de tourisme départemental ça a
été le début du mandat
ensuite sur l'aménagement du territoire
il faut connaître les acteurs donc quand
on s'est privé des personnes qui
connaissaient les acteurs c'est plus
compliqué de mettre en place un schéma
est d'ailleurs j'ai une boule recherché
je n'ai pas trouvé jeté ma départemental
d'aménagement touristique qui
normalement permet de structurer l'offre
départementale sur le tourisme on a
simplement voter dans ce département
des compléments ou des mises en oeuvre
du schéma régional d'aménagement
touristique qui lui porte une politique
département politique régionale sur le
tourisme et c'est bien normal puisque la
région est celle qui est chef de file
sur le tourisme avec laquelle on peut
être complémentaire on n'a pas besoin
d'être en guerre avec la région on peut
tout à fait complémentaire elle elle
propose un tourisme qui est durable qui
s'appuie sur les familles et je pense
que c'est l'avenir du tourisme parce que
la douceur de vivre dont je parlais peut
donner envie de prendre son temps au
bord de saône pourquoi pas puisque c'est
là que j pour dominique lotte cette
stratégie pour développer le tourisme
est assez coordonnés ou pas alors je ne
sais pas si elle est assez coordonnés en
tout cas l'idée c'est d'aller encore
plus grand en terme de coordination
on est un territoire plusieurs d'entre
nous l'avons dit on est un territoire
qui résonne au travers de ses paysages
de son activité de sa gastronomie tout
ce que l'on veut mais on est un
territoire en terme de tourisme un
territoire de passagers pas de séjour il
va falloir qu'on arrive à capter une
partie de ces populations au travers
effectivement d'une mutualisation des
acteurs des outils des opérateurs qu'ils
soient publics ou privés savez quand ce
que cherche aujourd'hui une partie des
touristes et et c'est probablement
renforcé avec la problématique que l'on
vient de vivre où les gens se
réapproprient peut-être quelque chose
d'un peu plus authentique et bien
essayons de leur proposer des choses
authentiques dans nos territoires
avec peut-être aussi l'hypothèse de
pâques touristique avec une diversité
d'activités plutôt que d'aller bronzer
idiot assure que vous passez des heures
plus l'on pense quand vous parlez
deux séjours plus longs pensionnés pour
le pendant longtemps un projet de
l'installation d'un data center parcs il
serait pas enterré vous le soutenez
toujours où on en est où vous par
exemple pas aujourd'hui c'est toujours
un projet qui semble-t-il est encore
dans les cartons de la part de pierre et
vacances
je ne sais pas on verra bien ce qu'il a
ce qu'il en sera réellement aujourd'hui
bien malin qui sait ce qui sortira in
fine et de la perspective mais vous
aimeriez que qui s'implantent vous avez
ce souhait a été quelque chose qui a été
soutenu en son temps et dont je fais
partie oui tout à fait vous vous rendrez
accary votre vision sur ce procès-là
saint projet de la majorité précédente
et d'ailleurs au départ lorsque s'était
présentée par arnaud montebourg
c'est un projet soutenu aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus de nouvelles
nous vous savez une habitude sur ce type
de projet en général ce qu'on présente
on le fait derrière voilà aujourd'hui on
n'a aucune visibilité sur ce projet mais
à l'époque effectivement nous avons
soutenu c est ce qui manque une grande
infrastructure de ce type il sait sur
laquelle on travaille non c'est sur
laquelle on travaille c'est le projet
notamment éclat un parc de spectacle et
justement historique et de spectacle est
donc là c'est pareil c'est quelque chose
qui se construit doucement et là on va
rentrer dans une phase de débat public
maintenant que les conditions sanitaires
nous le permettent et puis surtout que
en effet le le projet et commença à se
dessiner
oh rien du tremblement assemblée
nationale votre vision sur cette
stratégie sur le tourisme pour le
toujours une grande infrastructure qui
prennent leur part que c'est souhaitable
non il faut une grande infrastructure
type center parcs ou autre
le projet éclat me paraît plus tôt
très intéressant pour
l'avenir du département sur le point de
vue touristique bien évidemment si on
fait rayonner la saône et loire sur
l'ensemble du pays
bien évidemment que c'est un projet
intéressant mais nous nous savons
surtout ce que nous ne voulons pas sur
la saône et loire donc développer des
projets oui à étudier et ce que nous
voulons pas c'est l'implantation
d'éoliennes l'implantation des éoliennes
pendant cette campagne électorale
bon nom de l'association nous ont
contacté alors dans la stratégie
touristique
oui pour justement refuser ces
implantations d'éoliennes à savoir que
ces éoliennes font baisser 30 % le
foncier
c'est une arnaque et l'écologie qu'il
soit décidé par la dpi on a peur on peut
quand même pas vraiment a ajouté le
département s'y opposer et puis il y
figure également
nos paysages notre patrimoine c'est un
saccage de biodiversité et puis il faut
savoir que laisser les éoliennes une
fois implantées elle fragilise
finalement le monde touristique alors
c'est un vrai débat pour le coup pour au
niveau des régionales puisque c'est de
la compétence de la région de mini club
vous réagissiez jeu enfin encore une
fois on peut tout dire et son contraire
on peut à tout prôner la sécurité à tous
crins s'opposer au développement de
l'éolien supprimés
l'accompagnement des mineurs non
accompagnés dont c'est une compétence là
pour le cours obligatoire du département
et là monsieur le préfet nous chers
voisins si si vous aviez cette idée là
je pense que monsieur le préfet vous
tirer plus que les oreilles et et et en
contrepartie vous voulez que le
département assume des politiques qui ne
sont pas les siennes choisissez soit
vous êtes élu départemental soit on est
élu à l'assemblée nationale mais pas les
deux à la fois mon cher collègue de 38
question puisqu'on parle et dont on a
parlé des grandes infrastructures
la question également des grands
événements il ya eu un temps saône et
loire
un festival des francos gourmande c'est
un peu la volonté de la majorité
précédente 1 pas la vôtre celle d'avant
de développer un grand événement pour
pour attirer en fait du monde pour faire
connaître ce département est ce que
selon vous c'est souhaitable ce qu'il
manque un grand événement dans ce
département
oui oui parce que nous avons tellement
finalement de domaine sur notre
département nous pouvons penser à divers
grands événements aussi bien tourner sur
le viticoles ou bien sur le patrimoine
ou la gastronomie tout simplement que
nous retrouvons sur notre département
bien sûr que le dilemme alors on a perdu
effectivement les francos gourmand je le
regrette c'était un choix et à l'époque
on nous avait expliqué qu on allait voir
ce qu'on allait voir y allait avoir
beaucoup d'autres choses en terme
d'attractivité
il ya eu le contribuerait qu c'était le
projet je ne sais pas quels ont été les
résultats on n'en a pas eu le retour à
ma connaissance il ya eu la tour du haut
folin qui n'a pas été construite on
l'attend elle a été construite ailleurs
en france
donc pour l'instant j'ai vu beaucoup
d'investissement vous avez cité 350000
euros de communication vous avez oublié
les 300000 de l'an dernier sur lesquels
nous n'avons toujours pas non plus de
retour en termes d'impact apparemment il
semblerait compliqué de calculer des
retours d'impact communication dans le
département de saône-et-loire la voyeur
c'est possible mais je ne doute pas qu'à
un moment donné les touristes arrivant
je vous laisse répondre à karim la meuse
les confond un peu tous les dossiers
c'est son habitude elle parle de projet
qui était portée par la mandature
précédente elle a même oublié clinique
at nous n'avons pas cette habitude là
lorsqu'on présente un projet nous
derrière on le fait donc c'est vrai que
l'on fait toujours remarquer tirent sur
des projets qui ont été présentés comme
l'auteur de polars mais franchement le
la tour du haut folin je le rappelle que
c'était un projet porté et avec la
nièvre mais c'est un projet en effet qui
était présenté avant l'arrivée de notre
mandature et bien sûr la réponse est
intervenue mais je vous rappellerai que
les investisseurs privés à la femme
décide
ils ont décidé effectivement d'aller en
alsace parce que sans doute l'accueil
était meilleur mais je rappelle quand
même les grands projets phare de la
mandature précédente il ne reste plus
rien 1
nous n'avons jamais vu arriver cluny 4
nous n'avons jamais vu arriver pour
l'instant center parcs
et les francos gourmande largement
financé par les deniers publics avec des
sociétés notamment basé à neuilly sur
seine ont disparu voilà les oreilles
coupées dans un autre département est
ensuite attendu espéré par madame j'ai
le sens effectivement aller à tour et
pour vous répondre pour connaître le
dossier
il ya effectivement eu de l'argent
public qui a été investie mais de
manière transparente qui a été voté on
était sûr à peu près 400 mille euros et
morgan prod dont on parle qui fait par
ailleurs les francofolies de la rochelle
a perdu plus d'un million sur l'ensemble
des éditions des francofolies de la
rochelle société l'intérieur pas facile
de sauf bien sûr mais parce qu'ils sont
ils sont organisés comme ça mais je
pense pas que ça vous pose problème vous
qui êtes vous mêmes dirigeants de
société donc je pense que vous savez
comment ça avec 1 200 city parce qu'ils
ont rejoint les nations de la région ne
sont pas partis approche du département
bien suivre écrit officiellement ils
l'ont écrit officiellement j'aurais
juste un gagne à 17 ans à venir c'est
quand même éclat parce que ce projet ce
projet éclats dont on entend parler là
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on en ait
j'aurais aimé on entende parler
davantage dans l'hémicycle puisqu'on en
a parlé il ya plus de 18 mois
le président a carry s'était engagé sur
d'autres amendements à mettre en place
une commission de suivi puisque la
question se posait de l'utilisation des
terres agricoles de la préservation des
ressources et de la non utilisation de
l'argent public je constate
qu'aujourd'hui les choses se font de
manière très peu transparente avec des
agents publics du département qui
interviennent sur le terrain donc c'est
de l'argent public qui est déjà engagée
sur ce projet a priori plus ils vendent
raciale vous voulez intervenir
oui mais toujours concernant le projet
éclats je vais revenir sur la méthode
qui serait qui sera la nôtre nous nous
pensons qu'il faut d'abord coordonner
les acteurs locaux travailler avec les
acteurs locaux pour définir ce que l'on
souhaite faire est donc peut-être que ça
arrivera à un projet de type parc
touristique mais construit par les
acteurs locaux nous ne croyons pas aux
projets extérieurs qui arrive plaqué
comme center parcs ou les projets qui
sont plaquées de l'extérieur sans aucun
lien avec le territoire
et je rejoins violaine gilles est un
projet qui pour le moment est dans les
cartons
peut-être que certains connaissent les
tenants et les aboutissants de ce projet
mais il est présenté à personne et on va
engager la concertation une fois qu'il
sera totalement ficelé
si je rajoute la dimension écologique
est à dire c'est à dire là je vois comme
fait signe c'est à dire la prise de
terres agricoles
nous nous sommes contre ce projet pour
l'instant dans la forme qu'il a le
message est passé
j'aimerais ça on arrive
bientôt au terme de cette émission
chacun d'entre vous va pouvoir conclure
en 50 secondes
l'ordre a été tiré au sort juste avant
cette émission et c'est par vous que
nous allons commencer andré accary avant
que vous preniez la parole
on va montrer le les binômes qui se
présente face à vous dans votre canton
de paray le monial
il y en a deux autres un de gauche et un
du rassemblement national
la parole est à vous vous avez 50
secondes merci bien écouter cinq bonnes
raisons de voter pour les candidats de
la majorité des partenaires
c'est la première raison c'est la santé
avec la poursuite du recrutement des
médecins généralistes et des médecins
spécialistes
l'installation dans l'ensemble des
centres de santé et des ehpad de la
télémédecine la deuxième raison c'est un
département qui protège nos aînés nos
personnes handicapées en investissant
massivement sur le maintien à domicile
et puis la troisième raison c'est tout
simplement un bon cadre de vie avec le
plan environnement qui est en route
la quatrième raison c'est un département
attractif avec ruth 71 nos ambassadeurs
les voies vertes etc
et puis la cinquième raison c'est d'être
département qui préparent l'avenir c'est
à dire une 1ère sua qui sera terminée
fin 2023 à très haut débit qui sera fini
d'installer fin 2023 tôt comme ça aucun
territoire de la saône et loire ne sera
oublié très bien l'oreillette dutremble
vous avez tiré le numéro 2 même chose
devait être candidat je le rappelle sur
le canton de mâcon un sas à vous trois
binômes deux de droite et un dû ce n'est
plus l'autre c'est pas grave on les a
vus à l'écran et à partir de maintenant
vous avez 50 secondes 7 à vous alors
nous en étant présent sur l'ensemble des
cantons pour la première fois comme je
le disais tout à l'heure en 2017
les saône et loirienne et les saône et
loiriens ont fait confiance à marine le
pen est au rassemblement national à
hauteur de 39% en 2019 ils ont renouvelé
leur confiance au rassemblement national
pour les européennes et la liste menée
par jordan bardella
aujourd'hui nous demandons et nous
souhaitons que ces électeurs nous
continuer à nous faire confiance
bien évidemment sur l'ensemble du canton
et du département pardon et puis c'est à
nous c'est à nous aussi de prendre les
rênes
bien évidemment par canton nous sommes
là pour s'implanter durablement dans le
paysage politique du département
voilà merci numéro 3 viol et deux gilets
vous êtes candidate sur le canton 2 0
face à vous trois autres binômes de
droite de la majorité sortante 1 du
centre soutenus par la république en
marche et du rassemblement national
violaine gillet vous avez 50 secondes
c'est à vous nous sommes dans le groupe
gauche 71 des représentants de
l'ensemble du territoire de tous les
métiers confondus
un groupe qui s'est construit dans la
durée et qui a eu envie d'imaginer de
bâtir un projet pour les saône et
loirienne que je représente aujourd'hui
assez modestement sur ce plateau et
pourtant on était lui en binôme hommes
et femmes
voilà je le souligne je me permets et on
a construit ce projet aussi pour les
saône et loiriens bien sûr et dans ce
projet vous avez retrouvé les valeurs de
la gauche parce qu'on s'appelle gauche
71 on n'a pas besoin de se cacher et on
a la volonté d'affirmer d'afficher nos
valeurs on a des cours le courage de les
dire on est dans une volonté de
transparence et et de travailler dans la
constance de l'engagement parce que nous
croyons vraiment que c'est à plusieurs
qu'on peut trouver les solutions et à
plusieurs que l'on va je devais loin
c'est terminé c'est désormais au tour de
divan marissal vous êtes candidat sur le
canton de chalon 3 litres wadi normes
qui se présente face à vous s'affiche
actuellement sur votre écran un de
gaussin de droite et un du rassemblement
national vous avez 50 secondes 7 à vous
donc la crise du coc vie d'un mis en
lumière les effets destructeurs des
politiques libérales les dernières
décennies sur les services publics sur
les politiques sociales sur les
politiques de solidarité et les
principales victimes sont les
populations modestes et les coups 6
m nous ne pouvons plus nous contenter à
ce jour de simples aménagements
nous devons engager une véritable
rupture pour répondre aux enjeux de
justice sociale et de transformation
écologique il est nécessaire il est plus
que temps de répondre aux premiers de
corvée et comme je l'étais pendant le
débat qui sont souvent des premières de
corvée et donc effectivement on doit
avoir un travail avec ces personnes pour
cela nous porterons avec vous les
politiques sociales de justice sociales
comme le rsa jeunes ou du territoire
zéro chômeur et de transformation
écologique donc pour cela voter est
appelé à voter pour les listes des
collectifs de gauche
le printemps chalonnais changeons d'ère
à mâcon est également le printemps
citoyens appareils merci beaucoup et
enfin dominique lotte avant que vous
preniez la parole
je rappelle vous êtes candidat sur le
canton de gueugnon face à vous deux
binômes 1 soutenu par gauche 71 et un du
rassemblement national vous voyez leur
nom qui s'affiche actuellement sur votre
écran et à partir de maintenant
dominique lotte vous avez 50 secondes
il y à 7 à 8 ans le département était
une instance publique d'une institution
publique dont on se demandait quel était
l'intérêt notamment au niveau national
aujourd'hui plus personne quel que soit
le camp politique considère que le
département n'a plus son utilité
c'est le grand frère de nos populations
âgées de nos populations handicapées de
notre jeunesse et de nos territoires au
travers de ces communes et à de ces
intercommunalités
il nous faut au travers de cette
élection départementale sur le mandat
qui vient effectivement être innovant
être réactif et d'être en capacité à
pouvoir apporter les populaires et
réponses idoines à toutes les questions
de société qui se font jour donc
l'étiquette son et loire unis c'est une
étiquette qui veut se dépasser qui veut
innover merci votre temps est écoulé en
tout cas mercier avoue 5 d'être venu
débattre c'est fini donc pour ces débats
des départementales sur france3
n'oubliez pas d'aller voter le premier
tour c'est ce dimanche est également à
suivre toute la soirée électorale sur
notre chaîne bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]